I press we're [ __ ] doin it again I
read a lot of you bros comments first of
all I'm sorry III know you speak
Portuguese in Brazil so the more you
know I was wondering what he's languages
[ __ ] I know it wasn't really Spanish
either way I read a lot of comments that
you know there's gonna help me how to
play this game and stuff like that
you're not supposed to look at them on
this game is [ __ ] terrifying
if you haven't watched the first part I
feel I can't feel kind of bad for you
because okay 4 2 1 3
all right I got it I got to redo this
part so I'll see you in a second
[ __ ] oh not again League way get
out or leeloo me now
I'll come on ah he's fast
what am I supposed to have I scared my
yeah I'm scared my dog I scared myself
Jay says all right all right all right
hold on hold on it's gonna be fine
everything is gonna be fine
okay we're fine we're really [ __ ] I'm
serious okay hold the [ __ ] on hold on I
tell you you run run like you call that
one day are you serious I say run and he
becomes a [ __ ] snail
he just [ __ ] appears out of nowhere I
got I don't even know where he's gonna
come [ __ ] Jedi on it it's like when
you know in horror movies when the girl
has to run and she's always like oh my
ankle this this I'm playing as a girl
literally jaysis the restrooms also jab
lassic you keep on running running
running riding run
that's fun
ah what do I do
what disappeared still in this situation
it's not even [ __ ] funny back Paula
touch okay we're gonna back up I'm
backing up backing up backing that back
all right you didn't appear to shine
lovely now where the [ __ ] are we going
what the hell did I pick up I love
llamada oh I know where this goes it
goes in the bathroom over here put that
on cava I want the heart where's the
bathroom
I just really don't want to play this
right now brothers huh nay nay nay nay
night-night
jail I'll go to Lunas okay don't panic
don't panic don't panic don't panic
don't panic there we go - 3 2 d1 g
builds pot at that okay don't panic I'm
honey it's gonna be fine gonna be fine
it's gonna be fine oh that's okay that's
okay that's okay that's okay that's okay
that's okay that's okay that's okay
ah I think we're okay I think we're good
I think we're good
no no god diamond I am sweating like a
goddamn [ __ ] trans transformer this
is not good for my heart press that's
are you okay that your little sweaty too
huh that's her that's okay I'm fine I'm
fine thank you for asking
that's gonna be where do I put two three
three
oh wait wasn't there a people problem I
think there was let's find where that is
I would not be surprised if I get a hard
act laying this I'm not I wish I had my
heartbeat sensor it doesn't work like
vixx's I don't have the proper equipment
to set it up here anymore I gotta fix it
eventually but okay that's fine it's
fine
everything oh that's normal that's the
mom I'm pretty sure that delmos oh the
today low the pain oh yes the PO the
pineal that's Swedish I know that yet
you go that q3j one pitch
correcto what the hell oh let's play
horror games no nuts focus and char with
a buncha arrows ah
cheer with everybody arrows okay okay
cheaver their battles [ __ ] with the
matter we comes he's fine we're gonna do
this [ __ ] we gotta pull through stop
looking like a goddamn [ __ ] I meant a
cat not a [ __ ] okay okay okay that's
right just taller dice taller
just
just oh my gosh I sounded [ __ ] Dyson
what the [ __ ]
I cannot remember last time I was this
[ __ ] scared while hanging again yeah
okay I think we're good I think we get
that thank my god I thank my god I think
my god hello how are you doing sir hello
hello okay
oh yeah yeah hi hi hi hi okay it's gonna
be fine
that's gonna be fine it's all gonna be
fine hmm rain balls pants rainbows
unicorns colors happy place happy place
happy place happy place
Abigail what I wish I could [ __ ] save
Italy what does it say there one minute
or whatever France gotta income that's
yeah what is and contrabass one mean
each others and contraire
mais one mean eachother no it's Spanish
for for the gays
okay here we go here we go I doesn't
work all right
this is not gonna work okay but okay oh
no oh no oh no no no I don't know I'm
sorry I'm sorry